Now let's take a look at 802.11i.
802.11i enforces access control and
the access control
protocol is based on another
standard called 802.1x.
802.1x is flexible,
because it is based on the Extensible
Authentication Protocol or EAP.
EAP is designed as a carrier protocol
and it's purpose is the transport
the messages of the real
authentication protocols such as TLS.
In other words,
you can implement a host of different
authentication methods on top of EAP.
In other words,
802.1x can accommodate a host of
different authentication methods.
The more and advanced EAP methods such
as TLS provide mutual authentication.
This means that it will limit
man in the middle attacks.
Because it authenticate both the server
and the client to each other.
Furthermore, this EAP method
results in key material,
which can be used to generate
dynamic encryption keys.
That means the encryption keys
will change dynamically over time.
In addition, 802.11i supports good or
strong security practices.
For example, it uses different keys for
encryption versus integrity protection.
And it also uses stronger
encryption methods.
In particular, it uses AES.